problemas 70 y 52 aviones salen del
mismo aeropuerto viajando en direcciones
opuestas si uno de los aviones tiene una
velocidad promedio de 400 kilómetros por
hora y el otro avión tiene un promedio
de 250 kilómetros por hora en cuántas
horas la distancia entre los dos aviones
será de mil 625 kilómetros de hecho aquí
lo puse mal esto no son kilómetros por
hora son kilómetros la distancia está en
kilómetros no en kilómetros por hora
ok
continuamos bueno lo que nos específica
en este problema es que bueno tenemos
aquí el aeropuerto uno de los aviones
sale en esta dirección y va a viajar a
400 kilómetros por hora 400 kilómetros
por hora
y el otro avión va a salir en la
dirección opuesta
y va a viajar a
kilómetros por hora
estas flechitas son vectores así que no
sólo indican la dirección sino también
la cantidad de distancia que cubren por
ahora por eso es la diferencia en tamaño
de estas dos flechitas
y ustedes estuvieron a bordo del avión
que está aquí a la izquierda si ustedes
estuvieran aquí
y ustedes pensarán que están
estacionarios qué tan rápido se
alejarían ustedes de este otro avión de
la derecha bueno se alejarían ustedes de
este avión a unos 650 kilómetros por
hora
kilómetros por hora
lo mismo pasaría si ustedes estuvieran
sentados en este avión pensarán que
están estacionarios y el avión de la
izquierda se alejaría de ustedes a la
misma velocidad de 650 kilómetros por
hora este se convierte en un problema
estándar de distancia igual a rapidez
por el tiempo si queremos cubrir una
distancia de mil 625 kilómetros entre
ambos aviones será igual a sus
velocidades relativas así que la
distancia de
1.625 entre los dos aviones va a ser
igual a sus velocidades relativas que es
de 650 kilómetros por hora
la velocidad relativa entre ambos y la
rapidez relativa entre ambos y queremos
saber cuánto tiempo tan esto lo
multiplicamos por t vamos a despejar t
de aquí vamos a dividir todo entre 650
vamos a dejar que te es igual a
1.625 como las unidades kilómetros en
tren
kilómetros kilómetros por hora
estos kilómetros se van esta hora pasa
hacia acá y si hacemos la operación aquí
nos va a quedar
que es igual a
2.5 horas
2.5 horas si no me creen podemos hacer
los cálculos sacamos la calculadora
en
1625 entre 650 igual a 2.5
qué es la opción
la opción
ahora continuamos con el siguiente
problema que es el problema número 76
lisa preparará un ponche que tiene 25%
de jugo de fruta al agregar jugo de
fruta puro a una mezcla de 2 litros que
tiene un 10% de jugo de fruta cuántos
litros de jugo de fruta puro deberá
agregar
vamos a escribir nuestras variables
vamos a decir que p
significa son los litros y litros
hay este punto de litros
de puro jugo
o de jugo puro
puro jugo
esto es lo que quieren que encontramos y
digamos que m
es la cantidad de litros litros
de la mezcla de la mezcla
mezcla
del 10%
mezcla del 10 por ciento y nos preguntan
cuántos litros de puro jugo entran al
ponche entonces de los problemas nos
dicen qué
p litros de jugo puro más la mezcla que
la mezcla ya contiene algo de jugo
cuando jugó contiene la mezcla bueno el
10% de dos litros va a ser punto dos
litros de jugo
es más sabemos que está en
este mes igual a dos así que no los
debemos definir esta m es igual a 2
estoy resolviendo esto pensando en voz
alta y a prueba y error como ustedes lo
haría así que tenemos que es nuestros
litros de puro jugo más punto 2 litros
la del juego que está en la mezcla
cuánto de esto habrá en la mezcla total
así que esto es la parte del jugo de
fruta puro
entre la cantidad total de mezcla que es
la
los litros de jugo puro más los 2 litros
de la mezcla
y de toda la mezcla total deberíamos
tener un 25 por ciento
25 por ciento que es
0.25 eso es lo que debemos de conseguir
de puro jugo con esta relación
multiplicamos de más 2 en ambos lados de
esta ecuación nos va a quedar
0.2 igual a
0.25
25 x
+ 2
esto va a ser igual a punto 25 por p
0.25 p
+ 2 por punto 25 va a ser igual a 0.5
entonces repito en p más 0.2
vamos a restar punto 25 p en ambos lados
me queda menos punto 25 p de hecho es p
como aquí está p - punto 25 p +2 va a
0.2 perdón igual a esto logra este punto
25 p - punto 25 pero esto me queda 0.5
restamos punto 2 en ambos lados y
aprovechó para sumar esto p - punto 25 p
va a ser igual a punto 75
igual a punto 5.2 va a ser igual a punto
30.3 dividimos ambos lados entre puntos
75 está entre puntos 75 está entre
puntos 75 me va a quedar que p es igual
a si hacemos que
30.000
entre se aproximando aquí lo agregando
decimales para poder hacer la división
más fácil
375 haces este punto 3 en 3.75 pero
estoy multiplicando todo por 100 y esta
división
voy a poner aquí un punto
vamos a ver punto 4 4 por 5
20 7 por 4 28 más 2 que llevamos son 30
esto es una división exacta entonces p
va a ser igual a 0.4
ahora sustituimos este valor de p
aquí en esto aquí ponemos 0.4
punto 4 y nos queda esto punto 4.2
3.6 en
3.42
2.4
esto es igual efectivamente a punto 25
esto de aquí se está cumpliendo nuestra
proporción este problema estuvo bastante
interesante estos problemas nos muestran
cosas prácticas en donde se aplican las
matemáticas cuando ustedes preguntan
para qué me sirve aprender a álgebra
pues la van a ocupar para todo en
especial si van para alguna carrera en
ciencias en ingeniería o en finanzas o
en inversiones
pasemos al siguiente problema el número
uan relación es una función y nos dan
todas estas opciones recordemos que es
una función una función es una relación
que especifica una correspondencia tengo
que una función me va a especificar una
correspondencia desde un dominio que voy
a llamar de asia un rango que voy a
llamar r aún no hemos analizado esas
opciones pero el truco aquí es que si
tenemos un conjunto de números que
llamamos dominio de y otro conjunto de
números que llamamos rango r para cada
número del dominio habrá un número en el
rango siempre vamos habrá un número aquí
en el rango de aquí acá va a haber
siempre un número aunque puede haber dos
números en el dominio que lleven al
mismo número en el rango eso estaría
bien y se cumple sigue siendo una
función si tengo dos números en el
dominio que me llevan al mismo número en
el rango eso está bien lo que no puede
suceder
un número
en el dominio que mide un número en el
rango y que este mismo número del
dominio me de otro número en este rango
esto sí no se debe de cumplir en una
función veamos las opciones tenemos la
opción a da menos 1,3 normalmente los
números del dominio van a estar
indicados en el primer elemento de estos
pares ordenados estos números van a ser
los del dominio entonces tengo aquí
menos 1 - 2 está 60 aquí y aquí tenemos
otro menos 2 en el dominio que me está
dando un número diferente
este menos 2 en el dominio me da un 6 en
el rango aquí y este menos 2 me da un
menos dos en el mismo rango que es esto
el mismo número del -2 me está dando dos
números en el rango el 6 y el menos 2
que esto entonces que vemos que no se
cumple con una función así que esta
opción no es una función
- 2 - 2 0 a 0 1 a 1 2 a 2 pues pareciera
este es un buen candidato la
c4 en el dominio con le corresponde un 0
este 4 el mismo 4 del dominio tiene otro
valor diferente en el rango y de hecho
aquí todos los números del dominio son 4
y dan valores diferentes así que esta
tampoco va a ser una función la opción
de tenemos 7 en el dominio 4 en el rango
8 en el dominio 8 en el rango 10 en el
dominio 8 en el rango a pero también
tenemos 10 en el dominio y 10 en el
rango esto aquí tengo el mismo número
del dominio con diferente número en el
rango así que este tampoco es una
función
y respuestas la función es el inciso b
es así es una función y veamos el último
problema
a ver si cabe hay apenas ok 78 para cual
ecuación gráfica da a continuación son
todos los valores de negativos vamos a
ver tenemos que buscar una
gráfica que todos los valores de iu se
encuentren por debajo del eje x que es
donde está todos los valores negativos
de jeff y vemos que aquí en esta opción
que es la a
todos los valores de la función están
aquí hacia abajo de todos los valores de
y son negativos aquí vemos que hay
valores de positivos así que están no es
aquí se alcanza a ver que tenemos
valores de positivos de hecho estos son
puros valores positivos de esta opción
tampoco es y aquí también tenemos
valores positivos en que tampoco es así
que la respuesta a esta pregunta es la
opción